they are the assassins
[Music]
when I died the same year I looked at
the CCC
are you trying to poll
yes just be careful with possible
taking us because these things always
penico calm so they were seen before
possibly five two and possibly five pass
if it'll be when it is but the good
thing is a suit
[Music]
case
that's important
yeah
yeah yeah
on to hello hello hello can you hear it
can you hear me I can confirm it was
poisonous port Lakes yeah exactly
right
we
or something but we will get
it's it's
which would be adopted
yeah okay
yeah I hope so yeah okay but Cheers
I was a long time ago
yeah it was because I think our Phoenix
sky
long time
yes oh yeah
yeah that that's right that's why I mean
we were both in the end of the road the
tarpaulin was up the bus was
that's you
a lifetime ago
so that's a good sign
well
no I think it's gonna take two or three
ok Barney's 100 women it's the it's the
show of the day
Kimberly 100 women yeah
but she'll be off here at
no come on talk [ __ ] tell me some of the
theories
yeah exactly we have enough ice me
you know required
yes
well that would certainly be more
sensible yeah yeah want to go and talk
to the guys downstairs
Thanks thanks very much appreciated
cheers bye
Daniel Sanford
yes
well listen I'm not sure I'm even going
to be able to do anything for you I mean
people can't send me emails at ten past
fall
assuming that I can do the 1800 when I'm
all tied into other coverage I don't
reads coming down to try and work out
what the best solution is but I didn't
pick up the email too literally when I
replied to you there and I that is
literally the first I'd heard of
anything to do with 1800 so
yeah well listen listen it's got to come
through our guys and I'm Alan Reed will
come down there might be another
solution but I mean if it turns out to
be me the solution it's going to be me
I'm going to be like I can't not do what
I'm doing here now so it can mean me
leaving Scotland Yard maybe quarter past
five twenty past five going to Milbank
and writing a piece in half an hour and
drop it and dropping stuff in dude to
suit
well that Alan will come down and talk
to you guys and make a plan with you if
that's what we're going to have to do
that's what we'll have to do but you
know that isn't ideal and Alan read Alan
Reed is going to appear and
talk to you guys about and work out what
the best solution is but I'm but I'm but
I'm completely I'm completely tied into
coverage for other people at the moment
I'm nowhere near
well
yeah but put your slightly under bit of
pressure down yard where there were no
radio call other broadcast when you've
been denied and I'm hiding
which is going to happen it fine
say
yeah one two three four five four three
two one standing in the coldest street
in London
now that I switch to own I am you
someone's talking to me hello yeah hello
one two three four five
yeah hello
I'll catch you could
I'm hearing K parlays program
okay I'm also doing like
before
I'll be first when I treasure my soul in
the water
but listen I'm now doing the like to see
but you know
it's great okay I was kind of going
but no no it's not nothing all you
morons
do you hear a kind of
is it perfectly
Oh
yes okay yes God
i simian
and that was what the friend she works
there I was saying it somebody who had
worked there was Russian
do this
I understand attorney but certainly it's
not certainly people who just
and how we
if anyone ever kids then they say yes
pretty possible
what
Sally Davis
and that's not somebody this
and I think I think there's something
about
okay I'll just give me a second
participant
twenty past we think soon
Oh deep joy
just allowing you to get a little more
hypothermic
Daniel
was it the Russians
was it flattered me
achievement points
right I better stand in front
before they are they
yeah yeah
choose
I take it
sorry I will get out of your way
twenty past year yeah
they've done the life to nothing
yeah
I wish they'd come round with a hot
coffee
this'll never come around
Mike it's mark for your information it's
not 100% confirmed and not for broad
sorry gotta go I'm on life just I'll
call you back
yeah it was just been knocked by a curse
these things often are by another 50
minutes or so so we're expecting the
senior officer in charge of this
investigation Assistant Commissioner
Mark Rowley
out here on the steps to Scotland Yard
to give us an update on the substance
involved after you heard there from the
Home Secretary I'm burr Rudd confirming
that they would give more details on
that substance now exactly what it is
I'm told that we're not exactly going to
learn what that is but we will get an
indication of the type of substance so
for instance was it a chemical nerve
agent or perhaps fast-acting poison that
we don't know hopefully that will be
clarified perhaps with a little bit of
an explanation as well as to what that
substance could do to an individual how
potentially harmful it is we know of
course that Sergei greipel is critically
ill in hospital along with his daughter
at the moment and they their condition
we're told is unchanged at this stage
that will also be vital in identifying
their substance in terms of the ongoing
investigation and how that will enable
the authorities to determine perhaps
where it came from it this is a very
rare substance that's been used if we
tend to indicate the the chances of it
being criminal in nature are less likely
and perhaps point more firmly to a state
actor being involved again as I say it
all depends on how well they've isolated
the substance that was used and just how
rare that substance might be in terms of
the ongoing investigation of course they
will have been aided by the fact that as
we understand it was not a radio active
substance so if you think back to 2006
and the poisoning of Alexander
Litvinenko with polonium 210 that
radioactive substance it was quite a few
days before he was finally admitted to
hospital because he became so
we'll and a good few days after that
before they realized that he had been
the subject offer an attempt on his life
and of course at that time the trail had
gone cold although the authorities were
aided by the fact there was a
radioactive trail to follow in this case
there may not be a radioactive trail to
follow but they were on to it a bit
quicker it seems than they were at the
time of Alexander Litvinenko poisoning
so a lot of unanswered questions but
we're hoping around about quarter past
twenty past this hour we should get some
questions some answers to those
questions regarding this substance
perhaps even how it was administered
yes
yeah yeah
that's right yeah but you just keep over
us I'll try and give you some kind of
indication as to when that might be but
at the moment we're thinking about 20
past these things can keep slipping so
stay with us okay
sorry oh you're alive
hello mark yeah sorry I was just about
to go live there didn't realize that so
we're expecting that although not
confirmed the the chief medical officer
Dame Sally Davies Davi years may also be
here to to do a little bit of talking
presumably about the sub well yeah and
maybe about the substance as well you
know to you know maybe if it's you know
a reassurance message but you know
unless you were immediately sort of
contaminated by that you're fine type
thing I don't know exactly because I
don't know what the substance is but
yeah as a captain who knows
yeah not not confirmed and I see nothing
not for broadcast at this stage okay
Cheers thank you so sorry
just to let you know when my crew Lee
has spoken and he goes back up there
I'll be jumping in front of the camera
oh sure
No
yes I am you hearing me
okay right I need to get a position
where I'm not in everybody's can I be
over vision as okay you just bill at us
we're waiting for him to come out and
and do it that way
it's just otherwise I get in everyone's
shot
yeah is tell me when I'm creeping into
your short they just want to come back
to me just not so okay yeah
right what are we gonna do for quest bus
yes that's a fairly approximate time but
that is right
if I do alive and I come out there if
you see them walk out just just show
them we get me and I'll just know just
shout is fine discipline
oh yeah I need to know he's coming soon
concealer because you need to you want
to get shot of them walking down
yeah
well it's not me that's unhappy it's
just that you know when they say 20 past
it
uh-huh
I think yeah but I think you're still in
vision mine I think they're still okay
are you on sterile
you gotta yeah
just
thank you
yeah well it certainly will give us a
bit more clarification in terms of what
this substance was one of the the key
issues that people will be concerned
about of course is the potential for
other people to have been affected by
that now what we've been hearing really
over the last day in a bit from public
health England is that they do not
believe there is a risk to the wider
community having said that though on sun
those members of the emergency services
in particular who had close contact with
the two victims who were treating them
on the ground in salisbury city centre
and then at the hospital a number of
them became ill themselves we know that
as late as yesterday one police officer
was still being treated in hospitals so
there is clearly concern about the
substance and the potential for it to to
cause harm to others that could come in
contact with it so perhaps some
clarification of actually whether there
is any contamination of areas whether
they think it was a very localized
threat in terms of was it administered
directly on to sergey skripnikov read in
a wider area or wiped in a wider area or
perhaps put into the food chain we don't
know that that's the kind of questions
that we are clearly as a matter of
urgency trying to get clarified the
authorities know that it's the kind of
information that it's important to get
out to the public as well as a matter of
reassuring those members of the public
who might be concerned those living and
working around the Salisbury area who
might have been in the city centre on
Sunday afternoon when these events were
unfolding and that's why you had this
appeal again from Scotland Yard's who
have now taken over the full
investigation because of the unique
resources that they have within
counter-terror commands putting out that
appeal for men
the public who were in and around that
area of Salisbury late Sunday afternoon
and who might have some information who
might have seen the two victims who
might have seen any suspects and again
that's a question that we would like
answered the police might not be in a
position as yet to tell us whether they
are looking for a suspect or suspects in
connection with this incident but if
we're talking and we have confirmation
within the next few minutes of the
substance involved and if it was for
instance a chemical and nerve agent a
quick-acting
poison then that tells you very quickly
that this has gone now to a criminal
investigation and that the very least
are looking for one suspect maybe more I
was seeing a little earlier the
difference between this and the
Litvinenko case in 2006 is is the
passage of time the was about a day
really before the authorities were
properly on to this but that is a lot
less than the more than a week after
Alexander Litvinenko was poisoned before
the authorities really knew what they
were dealing with then so it gives them
some opportunity while it's fresh in
people's minds
well the CCTV to be gathered while
there's airports and ports perhaps to be
guarded as well to try to get a handle
on this and try to determine who might
have been involved in terms of the
substance that was administered here if
it is a quick-acting agent that we
believe it is whether it was chemical or
a quick-acting poison we don't know at
this stage it was a an interesting point
there made by Thomas More that it's
unlikely to be biological because of the
the fact that what both these victims
were incapacitated
it seems very rapidly and at the same
time and a biological agent within a
body well it just depending on someone's
you know system it can it can take a
different time to act on someone and
then it might on another
a chemical agent though applied at the
same time would probably incapacitate
the individuals at the same time and
that's one of the reasons of course we
were able yesterday to exclude a
radioactive substance from the
substances that were being examined by
those weapons inspectors at Port and
down not too far from Salisbury because
again that isn't a quick-acting
substance it can take some time before
the effects to take their toll and of
course as we saw with Alexander
Litvinenko he became really quite ill
that same day but he wasn't so
incapacitated that he required hospital
treatment until about four days after he
was poisoned so again it all really
hinges on the the information that we're
going to get from the head of
counter-terror Command on what this
substance was that will enable their
investigation to go forward and allow us
as well to get a clearer idea of what
we're dealing with
sorry James
and is it confirmed with Sally Davis
is she like is it like just a message of
reassurance sometimes like there's no
wife
yeah
okay within the next few minutes we're
told you about
what
Oh sky if you're hearing me that's the
one-minute warning
sky if you're hearing me that's the
one-minute warning when they're walking
down just keep my mic up for a second
one-minute warning because I'm going to
see the fact that Dame Sally Davis is
here as well
here he comes
come to ask I
good evening my name is mark Rowley an
assistant commissioner in the
Metropolitan Police and arleigh for the
Police Service on counterterrorism
another national security matters I'm
here with James Kelly Davis who's chief
medical officer finally short statements
and followed by James Sally then we'll
take two or three questions so I'm here
to update you on evolving investigation
into the incident where a man and woman
were taken seriously ill in Salisbury on
Sunday in summary this is being treated
as a major incident involving attempted
murder by administration of the nerve
agents as you know these two people
remain critically ill in hospital
sadly in addition a police officer who
was one of the first to attend the scene
and respond to the incident he's now
also in a serious condition in hospital
Wiltshire police are of course providing
every support to his family so whilst we
now know position to confer in a
position to confirm that their symptoms
are as a result of exposure to a nerve
agents I will not be providing further
information at this stage about the
exact substance that has been identified
we are working closely though with a
range of specialists and scientists
including public health England of
course Public Safety remains our joint
priority and this is clearly an awful
incident and I know that local people
will be concerned but I would stress
that at the moment we are not seeing any
evidence of a widespread health risk
don't Sally will update you further on
health advice in a moment so having
established that a nerve agent is the
cause of the symptoms leading us to
treat this is attempted murder I can
also confirm that we believe the two
people originally who became unwell
were targeted specifically our role now
of course is to establish who is behind
this and why they carried out this act
so that end we have hundreds of
detectives forensic specialists analysts
and intelligence officers working
together around the clock on the case
for example examining hundreds of hours
of CCTV and building a detail details
timeline of events specialist officers
in protective clothing will continue to
be visible in the center of Salisbury as
they go around there about their work
it's a sensible precaution and hopefully
will not alarm the local community we do
have well practice procedures for
dealing with chemical incidents I'm sure
you understand
that we need to be things painstaking
and thorough in order to protect public
safety and to secure the maximal ends of
forensic evidence indeed the work in
Salisbury may take several days
we have already asked the public's
health and thank you for those who
provide information so far today I'm
reiterating that we're asking for anyone
who hasn't spoken to us yet to get in
touch
that's anyone who visited calls returned
center all the surrounding areas on
Sunday afternoon this particularly
includes anyone who visited the area
close to the malting shopping center
where the two people were taken up in
particular anyone who visited Zizi
restaurant on Castle Street or the
Bishop's Mill pub in the Maltings
between 1:00 and 4:00 p.m. on Sunday
afternoon furthermore any members of the
public who have images or footage that
could assist the investigation should
send to our dedicated appeal website
www.moocchile.com and to work with a
range of agencies and will steer police
to prevent progress this investigation
as fast as we possibly can and we will
of course keep you updated as I say I'm
happy to take a couple of questions
after down-sized update but just to be
clear I won't be able to expand on the
investigative facts I've given you so
far Thank You assistant commissioner so
as your chief medical officer my message
to the public is that this event poses a
low risk to us the public on the
evidence we have our emergency services
responded fantastically for which I want
to thank them and public health England
have been in contact with all of them
and other people in the area about their
personal health all the sites that the
patient's were known to have visited
have been secured so the public are
protected so my thanks to the soup
staff of Salisbury District Hospital and
I particularly want to reiterate that at
this time with the evidence we have this
is a low risk to the public thank you
thank you so we'll take three quick
questions
No
I've been very clear with identifies
innervation that's helping our
investigation but I'm not gonna be
getting further detail at this stage at
Sky News do you know at all at this
stage how this nerve agent might have
been administered I've given you all the
investigative detail that I'm prepared
to and as I said I can't answer further
questions at this stage on that point
you put out an appeal for more
information possible pictures taken by
people in that area can you tell us the
couple that were seen going through that
alleyway on Sunday afternoon are they of
interest to the investigation so I'm not
gonna give specifics on individual
individual sightings but what we are
interested in people are taking photos
or seeing things any information in
beers got could be vital for the
investigation because I should
understand we're trying to piece
together a detailed timeline in terms of
the two victims who are in hospital
moment very seriously ill on their
movements so we can work out where
they've been who they've had contact
with and build a full picture for our
case thank you very much for your
questions good afternoon